Hello, I'm Daven Hiskey, you're watching the
TodayIFoundOut YouTube channel.
In the video today, we're looking at why it
is that in some countries people refridgerate
their eggs, while in others they don't.
Let's get started.
In supermarkets across the United States,
Australia, and Japan, eggs can be found in
the refrigerated section alongside other cold
items such as milk and cheese.
However in most other countries of the world,
eggs can be found stored at room temperature
alongside nonperishable food items.
People eat both kinds of eggs every day, usually
without any ill effects.
So why do some people refrigerate eggs and
others don’t?
The answer lies in the bacteria group known
as salmonella and how a particular country
chooses to make sure their eggs don’t get
contaminated with it.
Salmonella enters eggs through one of two
ways- via contaminating the egg internally
before the hen lays it (when a hen’s ovaries
have been infected); or via the porous egg
shell (when an egg comes in contact with contaminated
matter such as chicken manure).
Egg producers in the United States address
the salmonella problem with eggs by concentrating
on preventing the bacteria from entering through
the shell.
Towards this end, the United States Department
of Agriculture (mandates that all eggs be
washed with water at a minimum temperature
of 90 degrees Fahrenheit and at least 20 degrees
warmer than the internal temperature of the
egg at the time of washing.
(If it were colder than the egg, this could
result in a very slight contraction, sucking
in contaminated water through the shell’s
pores).
The eggs will also be washed with some form
of detergent and chemical sanitizer like chlorine.
They're then rinsed again and thoroughly dried-
the latter further helping to make sure pathogens
can’t easily find their way through the
egg’s thousands of pores.
After this, the eggs are often sprayed with
some form of protective coating like mineral
oil.
Finally, the eggs are taken into a room where
they are stored at temperatures at or below
45 degrees Fahrenheit or about 7 degrees celcius.
This effectively deals with the external sources
of salmonella (and helps ensure you won’t
accidentally contaminate other foods with
salmonella from touching a contaminated egg
shell then touching other items as you prepare
food).
However, this does nothing to destroy any
salmonella potentially already present within
the egg.
This is where the refrigeration comes in.
By keeping the eggs sufficiently cold, it
mostly makes sure any salmonella present will
not multiply sufficiently to cause problems
given a couple month shelf life, keeping the
eggs safe to eat so long as they are cooked.
Even for those eggs not internally contaminated
with salmonella, it’s still best to keep
them refrigerated if they have previously
been.
As scientific adviser to the International
Egg Commission Vincent Guyonnet notes, “Once
you start refrigeration, you have to have
it through the whole value chain, from farm
to store.
Because if you stop — if the eggs are cold
and you put them in a warm environment — they’re
going to start sweating.”
The United Egg Producers Association further
notes that condensation on egg shells “facilitates
the growth of bacteria that could contaminate
the egg.”
So why aren’t Europeans and others who don’t
refrigerate their eggs getting food poisoning
left and right from eating contaminated eggs?
They rely on other methods to keep the salmonella
problem in check and don’t refrigerate them
at any point.
For starters, the European Union prohibits
egg producers from washing their eggs.
You see, shells have natural protection from
salmonella and other contaminants via a waxy
substance known as the cuticle.
The cuticle coats the shell initially as a
liquid when a hen lays the egg and then dries
within minutes of being exposed to the air.
Egg washing, when done properly, may eliminate
surface contaminants, but it also washes away
the cuticle and its natural protection, potentially
allowing bacteria to get into the egg via
its pores or hairline cracks.
Both methods of eliminating external contaminants
are quite effective, but the washing strategy
requires that the eggs are processed in a
very precise way to be effective.
If, for instance, eggs are allowed to sit
in dirty washing water too long after losing
the cuticle, this would be an ideal situation
for microbes to quickly infect the inside
of the eggs.
Thus, the EU and others deem it safer to cut
out the potentially error-prone middle man
and simply leave the cuticle on.
Of course, by not washing the eggs at all,
the occasional egg with feces and other such
things will pop up (the egg being laid via
the same hole the chicken poops through and
the laying area potentially not being perfectly
clean).
But the fact that visibly dirty eggs will
most definitely turn off some customers and
that European Union egg farmers aren’t allowed
to wash the eggs is actually seen as a net-positive
by some.
For instance, Britain’s Egg Industry Council’s
Chief Executive Mark Williams states of this,
“In Europe, the understanding is that [prohibiting
the washing and cleaning of eggs] actually
encourages good husbandry on farms.
It’s in the farmer’s best interests then
to produce the cleanest eggs possible, as
no one is going to buy their eggs if they’re
dirty.”
Unfortunately, in this scenario you’ll still
get the occasional egg with fecal matter or
the like on it.
This also increases the chances of cross contamination
with handling the potentially contaminated
egg shells and then perhaps touching other
food items without washing your hands.
But both of these problems are easily solved
by simply washing the eggs (and your hands)
directly before using them.
So, the cuticle solves the problem of external
sources contaminating the inside of the egg,
but how does the EU and other countries that
don’t refrigerate their eggs deal with eggs
that were contaminated while being formed
inside the chicken?
They mandate that their egg laying chickens
must be vaccinated against salmonella, among
other requirements, if they are to receive
the Lion Quality Code of Practice seal.
The result of this is that approximately 90%
of chicken eggs sold in Britain come from
vaccinated hens, with the other 10% coming
from small farmers who don’t typically sell
eggs through major retailers.
So which way of storing eggs produces fewer
cases of salmonella induced food poisoning?
As the aforementioned Vincent Guyonnet notes:
“They’re different approaches to basically
achieve the same result…
We don’t have massive [food safety] issues
on either side of the Atlantic.
Both methods seem to work.”
But what about the exact numbers?
There seems to have never been any definitive
studies (at least that I could find), but
from the scant data we do have it would seem
on the surface that the European method is
the winner.
(Although there are uncontrolled factors that
could potentially be skewing the numbers,
so take this with a very large grain of salt.)
But On average, there are approximately 142,000
cases of egg-related salmonella poisoning
in the United States every year according
to the U.S. Department of Agriculture.
This is approximately 1 in 2,200 people infected
every year (give or take depending on whether
an individual is a repeat offender in a given
year).
In contrast, in England and Wales in 2009,
there were just 581 cases of egg-related salmonella
poisoning, or about 1 in 95,000.
Notably, before the British started vaccinating
their chickens in the late 1990s in response
to a major egg-induced salmonella outbreak,
in 1997 there were 14,771 cases of egg related
salmonella poisoning in England and Wales,
or 1 in 3,700, which is much closer to the
current 1 in 2,200 in the United States.
You might then be wondering why it simply
isn’t mandated that United States egg producers
vaccinate their chickens.
This is primarily because
when the last batch of rules concerning this
very thing were put together, the limited
number of large sample-size studies available
indicated vaccination wasn’t an effective
way to stop the internal contamination of
salmonella in eggs.
More recent vaccination methods and studies
have produced entirely different results.
Because of this, and the fact that henhouses
and eggs are now being continually tested
for salmonella contamination (with a positive
result meaning the egg farmer must break all
the eggs open from a batch and pasteurize
them, leading to significant profit loss),
approximately one-third to one-half of all
egg producers in the United States have recently
voluntarily begun vaccinating their chickens.
This voluntary adoption of vaccinations was
also spurred on in response to a 2010 egg-related
salmonella poisoning outbreak in the U.S.
resulting in half a billion eggs needing recalled.
To avoid such problems, more and more U.S.
egg farmers are jumping on board the hen vaccination
train every year.
In the end, while there are pros and cons
of each method of keeping eggs contaminate
free, both have proven extremely effective
when properly executed, though seemingly the
European method has a large edge in terms
of keeping people from getting sick.
However, if you’ve got a refrigerator handy,
it is superior method in one regard- eggs
that are not refrigerated have a shelf life
of about three weeks.
Those stored in a typical consumer’s refrigerator
are generally good for about two months, and
drastically longer given better regulated
temperatures, something that used to be key
to keeping eggs on the supermarket shelves
year round.
You see, naturally most chickens will stop
laying eggs in the winter as a response to
shorter daylight hours.
(There is a photo-receptive gland in a chicken’s
eye that, when exposed to sufficient light,
ultimately triggers the release of the hormone
that in turn spurs egg production when present
in sufficient quantities in the hen.)
This created an egg supply problem that used
to be solved by egg farmers in the United
States via keeping the eggs at the perfect,
constant chilled temperature not found in
your normal consumer refrigerator which is
regularly being opened and closed.
This allowed egg producers to store eggs for
as much as a year according to United Egg
Producers’ Vice President of Government
Relations, Howard Magwire.
Today, of course, the problem is somewhat
controversially solved with artificial light
and strictly controlled egg production environments
with the egg finding its way from hen to customer
generally in under a couple weeks, regardless
of what time of year it is.
So thanks for watching this video, if you
liked it, please click that like button below
and consider sharing it with anyone you think
might be interested.
And of course if you’re new to TodayIFoundOut,
don’t forget to click the subscribe button
to get more interesting videos like this.
We release a new video almost every single
day, so you’re sure to find something you
find interesting.
Thanks for watching.